Hi, Everyone from JSConf Korea
I am here to do a presentation about 'DIY Data Visualization in JavaScript while Stanning BTS"
and my name is Jiyeon Noh.
I shall begin the presentation.
The presentation will be in this order.
First before I start the presentation,
I want to talk about what motivated this personal project.
Let me introduce myself first.
Hello.
I am Jiyeon Noh, the presenter, developer, and an ARMY.
I was a developer working in a financial company when I was just starting out.
As I kept developing for the financial sector, I began to crave for a more serious development environment,
so I did Node.js back-end development in a startup company.
Then I got hooked on JavaScript,
so I wrote a book on JavaScript.
Jaedo Koh and I wrote the book together.
And now, I am working in Kakao Bank.
I am a software engineer that creates visualizations for the Kakao Bank BI platform.
Even though working in a company is my livelihood, and I like to work,
but actually, there is another job that I like.
That is, my job as a BTS ARMY.
I working with those hanging on my desk during work and I get energy from it.
Then I came across a question 'How could I make working more fun?'
Combining what I like, which are JavaScript and BTS
and what I do, which is visualization. I wanted to 'match my fan life and work life'.
So I searched for ideas
for my personal project.
It was winter of 2017 when I first began to like BTS,
and I want to talk about the song 'Tomorrow' of that time.
From these lyrics, from the song Tomorrow,
I was really consoled by the lyrics and empathized with them.
I got curious about 'Would other ARMYs be consoled by the lyrics?'
So I searched Twitter.
The lyrics comfort my life.
I am feeling frustrated these days,
but the sincerity of the lyrics console me deeply, are some of the tweets I found.
The second question was 'Why are we getting comfort from the lyrics?'
So my personal project is
aiming to find what is in the lyrics on the basis of data.
So began my personal project of matching my work life and fan life.
First of all, the process of my project is on this page.
I picked the topics from SNS, articles, journals, and more,
and went through a data processing, which includes research, planning, collecting, and preprocessing.
Then I did the analysis by SQL or keyword extraction.
Next is visualization using D3,
I will save the details for later.
Now, I will begin explaining the process.
Do you remember the topic I told you a while ago?
It was 'why do people get consolation from the lyrics?'
I got it from emphatizing.
As for empathizing, wouldn't it be the story the singer narrates,
or the story of our own,
and the sincerity that gives empathy to the fans?
And many different people have their own personal stories,
and there are plenty of stories that you can get empathy from,
so won't it be empathy that gives consolation?
Also, there is a broad emotional spectrum,
so won't there be various parts that people can feel empathy?
These three thoughts were my three points,
and these three points were divided into twelve indicators.
Lastly, these twelves indicators
and additionally
With such thoughts,
I though I could maybe prove the topics that I thought of,
or through the data here,
I thought, 'Can I discover new stuff that I didn't know?".
So, I'll structure the data now.
The data needed for the index I mentioned is the following.
Information on the album's song list, lyrics, composer and the lyricist.
And the storage to save these.
I made the table structure in PostgreSQL.
And I proceeded to research at the same time,
I had Naver Vibe Music API
and I brought the required data from there.
I made the script here using Node.js.
So, using Node.js, I collected the data
for BTS, EXO, GOT7,
and I'll tell you why I collected these three groups later.
And, I did preprocessing for the collected data.
I brought only the required data
and fixed duplicate songs.
And because the source data was local,
I did a process of mapping the information given by the API.
And the songs had many properties.
When I analyze the lyrics, I was going to do the new releases,
but because there were foreign language versions, remixes, or featuring versions, and full versions,
I did a filtering on the titles of each song to classify them.
Next I'm going to talk about the analysis.
First, talking about the keyword analysis,
there are many open source projects that deduces keywords.
Among them, I saw KR-WordRank and soynlp,
but, I chose Khaiii, the open source project that extracts the morpheme.
That's because, when we look at the results of keyword extraction,
it eliminated the words that I thought significant.
While it's right to take out the important unsorted keywords
from the movie reviews or critiques
when analyzing the keywords in general,
the lyrics that I'm working on has short sentences
and the words imply many meanings in each of them
and they are well-ordered,
I thought it would be a good idea to sort out the morphemes
to extract the keywords that I thought were important
So, Khaiii is
the morpheme analyzer that Kakao made.
First, I took a look at the comparison
on koalaNLP site and chose
an appropriate one.
The method was to analyze the morphemes in new songs
and extract the keywords.
Not all morphemes here were appropriated so I added a user defined dictionary as well.
I used only Korean.
Excluded Japanese
and numbers as well.
And in case of English, while they are important,
due to the characteristics of K-pop lyrics, they often are repetitive
in a way that they only add filer,
so I did the keyword analysis using Korean first.
And I did keyword sorting
with the output morphemes,
and the standard was whether they had meaning,
and they have frequency.
And with SQL,
so, I wrote the SQL using the selected 12 indices,
and I changed the data that I brought from SQL Query based on those 12 indices
into the forms to be presented,
and saved them as csv or json files.
You can see that the extracted results are listed on the file on the lefthand side,
and you can see the sample results on the righthand side.
So, if you extract the data like this,
you can't help but to think 'How should I present the results?'.
So, I'll talk about that now.
First, the result that I needed and the presentation
had two needs.
Let's present the data.
and let’s show them the story that I'm thinking of.
In fact, the reason why its called contents is not to be fancy
is because you can consider videos, games, photos, and texts like this
as a variety of created contents,
but they have to contain information or experience to be considered as one.
Therefore, I thought that the way to present these two together
was visualization.
As an example, to tell you why visualization is needed.
When I visualize the index data on the left,
word clouds shows the main keywords by frequency
effectively.
Therefore, I think the visualization is the one that shows the
key messages in the most effective way.
Then here, I was trying to think of a way to
make this easy and share it quickly.
This is the original way that I used.
In fact, there are many ways to implement
and it's the matter of a choice.
So, I wrote the contents like before
using HTML and wrote the contents and styled it
and implemented D3 using Javascript.
And you can see the visualized contents on the right.
But this is only shareable when you put it up on the server,
It doesn't let you interact
if you take screenshots or upload pictures onto a blog.
Therefore, what I was looking for was the Observable service.
It's actually a service that I found while studying D3.
You write down the contents using the markdown like Notion
to put the contents in a simple way
and the easy file upload and library import is its key point
Implement D3 using Javascript and hit the play button on the right upper corner
the contents shows up right away.
It's not 100% same as the Javascript,
but if you are a Javascript developer, you can easily make this.
So, deploy the result on the web right away
and you can share it.  I thought that it was its biggest strength.
And if I were to mention more of its features,
when I implemented the visualizations,
I was contemplating as to how I should visualize it.
At such times, there are gallery and search features in Observable
I could resolve the problem by referring to many examples
and because there are implementation code for them that were reusable
so that it didn't take too much time to implement it.
In fact, Mike Bostock of Observable also talks about this.
He mentioned that the reusing is a very good method
and while sharing, it is important to easily learn
and to take in more information.
So I could learn that sharing and learning are very good.
Therefore, at this point, I used the Observable service
to share the implemented contents.
So I'll show you the implemented results.
I'll tell you about my topic
and explain by points.
First, to tell you about the data sorting process,
the songs that BTS have made so far,
I looked at the numbers for BTS songs,
and I could see 38 albums and 226 songs.
Then, I took a look at how many new songs I needed to analyze the lyrics
and it was 161 songs.
I took a quick look at the development of new releases by years.
So I could see that they were actively making songs
Next, I wanted to take a look at the answer of sincerity
to question of why was I consoled by the lyrics,
and how much BTS contributed in the sincerity factor
So I Looked at how much BTS members contributed to the song making processes.
I could see that their contribution in composing and lyrics are
71% and 72% respectively.
I could see that their contribution rates were pretty high
looking at the contribution frequency by year
and
if you see the number of times each member participates
you can see they are all doing it continuously.
And a lot.
If you see here, you can see all the members.
From the members, RM participates the most.
You may not realize how
constant and abundant their participation is
so I prepared some comparisons.
I chose EXO and GOT7 because
they made their debuts similar to BTS
or have the same number of members.
Like before, I categorized the songs
following the debut year, EXO has the most songs
then BTS, then GOT7.
If you look at their participation
unlike BTS who had over 70%
GOT7 has 20-30%
and EXO has less than 10%.
If you look at the amount of participation
BTS' number is comparatively way higher.
So through this comparison, you can know that BTS participates a lot more
compared to other male idol groups.
Of course, this all may depend on their companies
and I'm not sharing this information to
create a rivalry among the groups.
Their participation rate and
now that we looked at their genuineness towards their songs
let's see what kind of stories they are trying to share
through their lyrics.
First, I tried to explain
how I started this content with some photos
if you look at TOP10 keywords in the lyrics
our most used pronouns
me, you, we, my, your
are the ones in the ranking.
But it's natural for these words to come up in the lyrics
and they come up a lot
and these words decrease the frequency of
other keywords so
we should just recognize how frequently they come up
and exclude it from the analysis.
I made a word cloud of the keywords
in the lyrics.
You can see words like
love, dream, speech, world, and person exist
and you can also see a lot of other words.
Just seeing this word cloud felt too general
so I made keywords by year.
Early in their debut, members' origins
such as Jeolla-do, Gyeonsang-do, Chungcheong-do, and Seoul appear.
The year after that is dream and love.
After that, they talk about social issues such as
spine breaker and padding jacket.
Just seeing up to here, I couldn't really feel
how diverse their stories were.
I couldn't make any conclusion
so I made comparisons again.
I looked at TOP50 keywords.
If you look here, the words used by BTS
is similar to words used by other groups.
I thought the keywords I got
applied to BTS alone.
But I started to wonder now that I have seen
how similar the keywords are
so I did some analysis below.
So I did another process to really look for the diversity within the lyrics.
I just had to look at BTS's stories.
To look at BTS's stories, I eliminated all the keywords
that overlapped with other male idol groups
and ended up with 1686 keywords.
Looking at those keywords
I was able to categorize them into groups
so I did.
I chose keywords that occurred more than 2~3 times.
Since I'm an ARMY,
if you see anything that could use some improvements, please let me know in the comments.
So, the categorization that I saw with a frequency that is higher than 3 is like this.
When I do it higher than two, I can see more keywords.
I took a look at other categorizations with 2 or higher,
and there were two things that I focused.
First of all, I could tell that BTS
are not reluctant to talk about themselves.
As I said, talking about their origins,
for example Seoul or Jeolla-do,
or when they were teenagers prior to their debut,
they listed the words such as
cellphones, the national college entrance exams that teenagers could relate to.
With that being said, I could see that their sincerity or
their participation gets higher
and the second thing that I saw was
that how they talked about a variety of stuff.
In general, popular stories
tend to contain the topics such as love, parting, and encounters,
but BTS talked about keywords regarding social issues
such as dependency on parents, gold spoon that tells us about the social issues of the time,
and in emotional sense, rather than talking about love, troubles, partings,
but they talked about anger, hope, respect, pride,
or hatred, hypocrisy, they told the stories
that have large spectrum of emotions.
And, though I couldn't classify, because they have higher frequency,
but if you take a look at the other words listed,
they talk about artists,
religious faiths,
and foods, Hangang River,
they talk about the stuffs that people talk about a lot
while they are not mentioned often in lyrics.
So, I could see that it's focused on these two things
with the data,
and after a proper introduction, I finished up the personal project.
So, back to the topic,
I'll summarize what were in the BTS' lyrics.
Through the lyrics
that BTS delivered themselves
and what they weren't reluctant to say,
with wide spectrum of the emotions, and that were not usually talked about in other lyrics.
I think they brought out sympathy from people
and consoled people through that sympathy,
that's how I thought.
So, what my project delivers is,
actually, just by listening to the music, you can catch these things.
But, I look at the data and create visualization contents
so I think I've done quantitative analysis.
Also, I think it was a process that persuaded the public about the consolation and the sympathy
that BTS offers with such analysis.
To wrap up,
just to tell you that what I'm going to be doing after this project,
I think I'll keep studying D3.
I'm looking through the official postings or other people's postings in Observable
and adding tutorials one by one as well.
And I also have a desire to grow the projects that I've done and add more keywords
or do some emotion analysis
on a sentence by sentence basis.
And I'll keep on making visualizing contents on Observable
and share them.
This is it for the presentation.
I'm not sure how you liked it
but I‘d like to thank JS CONF
for giving me this opportunity to share this,
and I wish well for the people who are feeling frustrated and having a hard time due to corona.
I hope to have more pleasant opportunities to share the project
with other people who conduct personal projects.
Thank you.